Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. On the evening of 11th September 1683, in the hills outside Vienna, the Polish King Jan Sobieski launched what remains the largest cavalry charge in history. Within the hour his hussars had smashed the morale of their Ottoman opponents and driven them from the field. The siege of Vienna was lifted, the tide of Ottoman imperialism was turned back, and in that moment, it's often said, the balance of power between Christendom and Islam changed forever. So when exactly 20 years ago Osama bin Laden chose the same date, the 11th of September,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1683年9月11日傍晚，在维也纳郊外的山丘上，波兰国王扬·索别斯基发起了至今仍是史上规模最大的骑兵冲锋。不到一个小时，他的骠骑兵就彻底击溃了奥斯曼敌军的士气，将其驱逐出战场。维也纳之围就此解除，奥斯曼帝国主义的势头被逆转，人们常说，正是在那一刻，基督教世界与伊斯兰世界之间的力量对比永远地改变了。因此，当本·拉登在整整20年前选择同一天——9月11日
to launch his attacks on New York and Washington DC, he did so very deliberately. This was his attempt to reverse what Jan Sobieski had done outside Vienna and to pull off a similarly spectacular world-changing victory that would be remembered for centuries to come. But will it? Tom Holland, will 9-11 be remembered as long as the siege of Vienna? That's a very good question. I suspect it will because it was filmed. Yeah. And I think that anything that's filmed is destined to last. And that was a key aspect of 9-11, was that it was designed to have an incredible visual impact. Yeah. Planned as a spectacle, wasn't it? It's planned as a spectacle. Yeah. I don't know. I mean, so we're doing this obviously because it's the 20th anniversary of 9-11,
来对纽约和华盛顿特区发动袭击时，他是蓄意为之的。这是他企图逆转扬·索别斯基当年在维也纳城外所做的一切，并企图复制一场同样壮观、改变世界、并在未来几个世纪都被人铭记的伟大胜利。但事实会如此吗？汤姆·霍兰，人们对9·11的记忆会像维也纳之围那样持久吗？这是一个很好的问题。我猜会的，因为它被拍摄下来了。是的。我认为任何被记录成影像的东西都注定会流传下去。这也是9·11的一个关键方面，那就是它被设计成具有难以置信的视觉冲击力。是的。作为一场奇观来策划的，对吧？它是作为一场奇观来策划的。是的。我不知道。我的意思是，我们之所以做这个节目，显然是因为今天是9·11事件20周年，
which when it happened felt like the most seismic of global events. Yes. I mean, do you feel it's kind of maintained that status 20 years on? That's a really interesting question because I think it's a very good example of how the meaning of historical events changes over time, isn't it? I think it felt like, in my lifetime, I would say there are two global events that felt absolutely earth shattering. And one was the fall of the Berlin Wall wall and 9-11 was the other one.
在当时看来，这仿佛是全球最具震撼力的事件。是的。我的意思是，你觉得20年过去了，它还保持着那种地位吗？这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为我认为这是一个极好的例子，说明了历史事件的意义是如何随时间而改变的，不是吗？我认为在我的有生之年，可以说有两件全球性事件让人感到绝对震撼。一件是柏林墙的倒塌，9·11是另一件。
But of course, 9-11 was more visceral because as you say, it was planned as a spectacle and it felt like something from, you know, it felt unimaginable, but it felt at the same time, like something you'd seen at the cinema. And the meaning of it now, 20 years on, particularly in the aftermath of the retreat from Afghanistan, feels different, doesn't it? Because we now know what happened next. So we know that it led to two wars. It led indirectly, anyway, to two wars in Afghanistan and Iraq, both of which involved hundreds of thousands of casualties and didn't end well for the West. So I think it will always be remembered.
但当然，9·11更触动人心，正如你所说，它是作为一场奇观策划的，感觉就像是……你知道，它感觉不可思议，但与此同时又像是你在电影里看到的那种场景。而20年后的今天，它的意义，特别是在从阿富汗撤军之后，感觉有所不同了，不是吗？因为我们现在知道了接下来发生了什么。所以我们知道它引发了两场战争。它间接导致了阿富汗和伊拉克两场战争，这两场战争都造成了数十万人的死伤，而且对西方来说并没有好结果。所以我认为它将永远被铭记。
But a bit like, I mean mean this is such a hackneyed I feel ashamed of myself for even making it but it does feel a bit like the assassination of Franz Ferdinand as in 1914 the trigger for the First World War because it did trigger wars
但这有点像——我的意思是，这个比喻太老套了，我都为自己用它感到羞愧——但它确实有点像弗朗茨·斐迪南大公遇刺案，就像1914年第一次世界大战的导火索一样，因为它确实引发了战争，
that unfolded as the protagonists did not expect but I guess the difference is that 9-11 was also loaded with all kinds of cultural, kind of intellectual, ideological meanings, wasn't it? About the clash of civilizations and about Islam and the West and modernity against supposed medievalism and so on, which is kind of your territory really. Yes. I mean, I guess that was pretty much how I certainly saw it.
其发展是当事各方始料未及的，但我想不同之处在于，9·11还承载了各种文化、知识、意识形态方面的意义，不是吗？关于文明的冲突，关于伊斯兰教与西方，以及现代性对所谓中世纪主义等等，这其实是你的专业领域。是的。我的意思是，我想这差不多就是我当时的看法。
It was almost impossible not to see it through the prism of those East-West, Islam, all that kind of stuff. But I think now that my take on it would be that it was really about globalization. Right. I think. And I think that oddly, in that sense, Bin Laden and George Bush are kind of on the same side, almost. I mean, it sounds a kind of heretical thing to say. Because they're universalizers, do you think? Both of them are universalizers. So if we go back to the Islam-Christianity thing, the thing about Islam and Christianity is that they're both universalist, missionary faiths.
几乎不可能不通过东西方、伊斯兰教以及所有这些视角来看待它。但我想现在我对它的看法是，它其实关乎全球化。没错。我认为。而且我认为奇怪的是，在这个意义上，本·拉登和乔治·布什其实有点站在同一边。我的意思是，这听觉起来像是一种离经叛道的说法。因为你认为他们都是普世主义者吗？他们两人都是普世主义者。所以如果我们回到伊斯兰教与基督教的问题上，伊斯兰教和基督教的共同点在于，它们都是普世的、传教性的信仰。
They both feel that they have a kind of a right, a duty to spread their understanding of the world for the good of humanity as far as they possibly can. And Bin Laden and Bush were both the heirs of those assumptions. But I think also they're both expressive of that very distinctive moment in the 90s and the early noughties that we talked about before on the 90s episode, where globalization is seen as as a positive yes but lots of people hate it and actually both bush and bin laden come a cropper because they overestimate people's readiness to embrace a kind of globalized world i think yeah i think i think there's a lot
它们都觉得为了人类的福祉，它们有一种权利、一种责任，尽可能将他们对世界的理解传播得更远。而本·拉登和布什都是这些假设的继承者。但我也认为，他们都表达了90年代和20年代初那个非常独特的时刻——正如我们之前在90年代那一期节目中讨论过的——在那里，全球化被视为一件积极的事情，是的，但很多人讨厌它，实际上，布什和本·拉登最终都碰壁了，因为他们高估了人们对拥抱这种全球化世界的接受程度，我觉得是的，我觉得有很多
of truth in that i mean i was thinking about this yesterday and reading up on the sort of 1990s context so that the 9-11 um is obviously much closer to the fall of the berlin wall than it is to us now i mean it's 10 years or so from the fall of the berlin wall 12 years and it's 20 years away from us um and i think it it kind of the way one way that i would make sense of it is in the back after all the stuff you know francis fukuyama and the end of history, his argument, the Western liberals. I mean, that's the classic universalizing argument. The Western liberal, that history is this sort of Hegelian struggle of ideologies. And the last one, the last man standing is liberal democracy. And that that is going to, you know, that is going to conquer. But there are also books like in 1990, I mean, so early, actually, in 1992, a guy called Benjamin Barber wrote an article in The Atlantic called Jihad versus McWorld.
道理。我的意思是，我昨天还在想这件事，并查阅了90年代左右的背景资料，所以9·11嗯，显然比它到我们现在的距离更接近柏林墙的倒塌——我的意思是，它距离柏林墙倒塌大约10年，12年，而距离我们现在已经20年了嗯，我认为……我理解它的一种方式是，在所有这些事情之后，你知道弗朗西斯·福山和“历史的终结”他的论点，西方自由主义者。我的意思是，那是典型的普世主义论点。西方自由主义认为，历史是意识形态的一种黑格尔式的斗争。而最后一个站着的人是自由民主。并且那将……你知道，那将取得胜利。但也有一些书，比如1990年的——实际上很早，1992年，一个叫本杰明·巴伯的人在《大西洋月刊》上写了一篇文章，叫《圣战对决麦当劳世界》。
Became a book a year later, very successful at the time, saying, you know, there were two, basically, that there were two forces that will decide the course of human affairs. One is globalization and the other is, I think, what he called tribalism. So he basically... But he's equating tribalism with jihad yeah but he's using jihad very he's using it loosely actually he doesn't just mean islamic fundamentalism he means i get i think he gets that spectacularly wrong because i think the whole point the whole point about bin laden is that he like bush is an internationalist yeah yeah and and that's And this is a sense that's been very much sharpened by what's going on in Afghanistan at the moment. Because the point about the Taliban,
一年后成了一书，当时非常成功，他说，你知道，基本上有两股力量将决定人类事务的走向。一股是全球化，另一股是，我想他称之为部落主义。所以他基本上……但他把部落主义等同于圣战。是的，但他对圣战的使用非常……他其实用得很宽泛，他指的不仅仅是伊斯兰原教旨主义，我是说，我觉得他大错特错了，因为我认为关于本·拉登的核心在于，他像布什一样是个国际主义者，对，对，而且这是……
where bin Laden took refuge, is that the Taliban regarded bin Laden with considerable suspicion when he took refuge there. I mean, they viewed him as a kind of a problem that had been left in Afghanistan by the warlords that bin Laden had been fighting with and who the Taliban had overthrown. And specifically, they were suspicious of bin Laden. They were suspicious of the fact that he appeared on TV, Taliban banned TV. They were suspicious of the kind of the rootless cosmopolitanism. Well, the modernity of Al-Qaeda, right? Of all the various people from the various Arab countries that had come to join bin Laden.
而目前阿富汗正在发生的事情让这种感觉更加强烈。因为关于塔利班的一点是——本·拉登曾在那里避难——塔利班在收留本·拉登时对他抱有相当大的疑虑。我的意思是，他们把他视为阿富汗军阀留在当地的一个麻烦，本·拉登曾与这些军阀并肩作战，而这些人后来被塔利班推翻了。具体来说，他们对本·拉登心存怀疑。他们怀疑他竟然频频出现在电视上（塔利班是禁播电视的）。他们怀疑这种根基全无的世界主义。好吧，就是基地组织的现代性，对吧？对所有来自各个阿拉伯国家、前来加入本·拉登的各种各样的人。
They were suspicious of this. Just as conversely, bin Laden regarded the Taliban with a kind of measure of contempt, a kind of, you know, a globalist contempt for bumpkins because they weren't interested in global jihad. Tom, let me just, our producer is saying we should remind people who Osama bin Laden was. Yes, we should. That seems an extraordinary thing to say,
他们对此抱有戒心。正如相反，本·拉登对塔利班也带有一种轻蔑的态度，一种……你知道的，由于他们对全球圣战不感兴趣，因此作为全球主义者对乡巴佬的轻蔑。汤姆，让我插一句，我们的制作人说我们应该提醒大家奥斯曼·本·拉登是谁。是的，我们应该这么做。这听起来像是一件不可思议的事情，
but of course, he's quite right. Younger listeners, we assume, of course, that everyone is as steeped in this as we are, but it is 20 years ago. So give us a very quick sort of bio of Osama bin Laden, but very broad brush. So Osama, well, I think actually we should pull the camera out even further and we should try and just look at, just explain what built up to 9-11 and then the aftermath for people who may not be
但当然，他说得完全对。对于年轻的听众，我们理所当然地认为每个人都像我们一样对这段历史耳熟能详，但这已经是20年前的事了。所以给我们简单介绍一下奥斯曼·本·拉登的生平吧，大致勾勒一下轮廓。所以奥斯曼……好吧，其实我觉得我们应该把镜头拉得更远，我们应该试着去看看、解释一下是什么促成了9·11，以及随之而来的后果，以便那些可能对它
particularly familiar with it. So the context that I think is provided by the way in which the West's universalism over the past two centuries has come to put in the shade Islam's claim to universalism. And in the Muslim world, there have been various responses to this. Accommodation, ranging from to outright opposition. In the 90s, when it looked, as you said, the end of history, the triumph of the West, liberal democracies prevailed everywhere. This sharpens and hardens a feeling among Islamic radicals that this Western triumphalism has to be opposed. a Saudi, Osama bin Laden, skin of a very, very kind of prosperous Saudi industrialist family, making concrete and all kinds of things like that. He's, I think, the 19th son or something like that. And he goes off, as romantic young men have always done, to go and fight for noble causes. And his cause is fighting the Soviets and then in Afghanistan.
并不太熟悉的人能够了解。所以我认为其中的背景是：过去两个世纪里，西方的普世主义如何将伊斯兰教对普世主义的主张压制得黯然失色。在穆斯林世界，对此有各种各样的反应。从妥协顺应，到彻底的反对。在90年代，正如你所说，当“历史的终结”和西方的胜利看起来让自由民主无处不在时。这加剧并巩固了伊斯兰激进分子的一种感觉，即必须反抗这种西方的凯旋主义。……一个沙特人，奥斯曼·本·拉登，来自一个非常非常富裕的沙特实业家家族，涉足混凝土和各种类似产业。我想他是第19个儿子左右。他像历代的浪漫青年一样，出发去为一个崇高的事业而战。而他的事业就是打击苏联，然后是在阿富汗。
The Soviets leave. Bin Laden comes to the conclusion that America, the great Satan, and Satan in Islam is a tempter. It's not quite the embodiment of evil that he is in the Western imagination. He's the tempter. So America is the great Satan. Bin Laden comes to think that rather than fight local wars, as the Taliban have been doing in Afghanistan, what is needed is to join Muslims across the world in a common battle against their common enemy, because bin Laden comes to see that all these kind of local battles, the fact that there is infidel influence in Afghanistan, the fact that after the first Iraq war, there are American troops in Arabia, and Mohammed had specifically said that there should be only one faith, only one deed, only one religion in Arabia, that this is an outrage that across the entire Muslim world, the West is kind of intruding and particularly America. And therefore, they need to take the fight to the Americans. And so he forms this group, Al-Qaeda, which basically means the foundation, the base, to launch the fight back.
苏联人撤走了。本·拉登得出结论：美国，这个“大撒旦”——在伊斯兰教中，撒旦是一个诱惑者。它并不完全等同于西方想象中的邪恶化身。他是诱惑者。所以美国是伟大的诱惑者。本·拉登开始认为，与其像塔利班在阿富汗那样打地方战争，不如让全世界的穆斯林联合起来，共同抗击他们共同的敌人，因为本·拉登逐渐看出，所有这些地方性的战斗——阿富汗存在异教徒的影响、第一次海湾战争后沙特阿拉伯境内驻扎了美军，而穆罕默德曾明确指出阿拉伯半岛只能有一种信仰、一种律法、一种宗教——这是一种令人发指的行径，西方正侵入整个穆斯林世界，尤其是美国。因此，他们必须把战斗直接带到美国人那里去。于是他组建了这个名为“基地”的组织，基本意思是“基础”或“基地”，以此发起反击。
And he comes to the conclusion that the best way to do this is to attack America in its homeland. And so he recruits various young men to embark on a martyrdom operation. They will go to America. They will learn to fly. And on 9-11 or the 11th of september as we call it yeah um they uh they fly the plan is that they will fly four planes into various icons of american financial military and governmental power so the twin towers of uh in uh in new york which comes off the pentagon which comes off and either the capital or the White House. This doesn't come off because the people on the hijacked planes realize what's happening,
他得出的结论是：实现这一目标的最佳方式是在美国本土袭击美国。于是他招募了几名年轻人，踏上了一次自杀式袭击的行动。他们将去美国。他们将学习飞行。然后在9·11——或者我们所说的9月11日——是的，他们……他们的计划是用四架飞机撞击美国金融、军事和政府权力的各种象征。因此，纽约的双子塔得手了，五角大楼得手了，还有国会大厦或白宫中的一个。这个没有得手，因为被劫持飞机上的乘客意识到了发生了什么，
force the patrols to crash the plane. I mean, unbelievably moving story, even now, 20 years on. When you read it, you kind of feel your eyeballs prickling at the storming that are coming down and everything yeah it's it's powerful stuff and all of this of course is being played out as you say on television um you know this is the first age where kind of messages can can bounce around the world um the internet is cranking up um and so it's it apart from anything else, it's an incredible spectacle. Yeah, it is. And it's devastating for Americans in particular, both for that reason, but also because they've been attacked on American soil. And America had come to see itself as being basically impregnable within its own homeland.
迫使劫机者让飞机坠毁。我的意思是，这是一个极其感人的故事，即使在20年后的今天也是如此。当你读到它时，你会觉得眼眶发热，那些坠落的瞬间和一切……是的，这是充满震撼力的力量。而所有这一切，正如你所说，都在电视上上演着……你知道，这是信息能够在全球范围内传播的第一个时代，互联网正在兴起，因此，除此之外，它是一场令人难以置信的视觉奇观。是的，确实如此。对美国人来说，这具有毁灭性的打击，不仅因为这个原因，还因为他们本土遭到了攻击。而美国此前一直认为自己的本土基本上是坚不可摧的。
And so the question then becomes, well, what are they going to do? And President Bush, who's been flying all around America and various bases on 9-11 itself, decides that they're not going to treat this as a criminal operation. They're not going to treat it as a police matter. They're going to treat it as something altogether more existential. America is at war, and it is at war with terror. Well, let's come to that. Let's come to the reaction a little bit later. But let's unpack a couple of things there. So Osama bin Laden, it's often said that al-Qaeda and bin Laden and so on, they were mad, irrational, and so on. But actually, he published numerous statements explaining quite sort of specifically his goal, his objections and his goals. And the two things that come up again and again are obviously American support for Israel. But one of them is that thing that you mentioned about American troops in Saudi Arabia. And that's obviously a consequence of the Gulf War. And a little known fact is that
因此，问题就变成了，他们将如何应对？布什总统在9·11当天乘专机飞往美国各地和各个军事基地，他决定不把这当作刑事案件来处理。他们不打算把它当作治安问题来处理。他们打算把它当作一件更具生存危机的事情来处理。美国处于战争状态，它正在与恐怖主义进行战争。好吧，让我们谈谈这个。让我们稍后讨论一下各方的反应。但让我们先剖析其中的几个要点。所以关于奥斯曼·本·拉登，人们常说基地组织和本·拉登等人是疯狂的、非理性的等等。但实际上，他发表了大量声明，相当具体地阐述了他的目标、反对意见以及他的目标。而不断出现的一再提及的两件事，显然是美国对以色列的支持。但其中之一就是你提到的美国军队驻扎在沙特阿拉伯的事情。这显然是海湾战争的结果。而一个鲜为人知的事实是，
bin Laden had offered his mujahideen to the Saudi king to protect them against Saddam Hussein, when everybody thought that Saddam was going to go on from Kuwait and attack Saudi Arabia. And the king of Saudi Arabia said, no, thank you. I can live without your 50 ragtag men. I'd rather have the US military. And bin Laden is absolutely incensed by this. And my question to you, Tom, is how much do you think that's shared? I mean, how much is that personal peak in a way that his homeland has got American troops in it and he has this animus against America? And how much is that more widely shared, a sort of sense of outrage that American troops in particular, the embodiment of Western modernity, are guarding the holy places, as it were. I think it's a kind of... The embers are definitely hot and they can be blown on.
本·拉登曾向沙特国王主动提出派遣他的圣战者去保护他们免受萨达姆·侯赛因的攻击——当时所有人都认为萨达姆会乘胜从科威特进攻沙特阿拉伯。而沙特国王却说：不，谢谢。没有你那50个乌合之众我也能过。我宁愿要美军。本·拉登对此感到愤怒至极。我的问题是，汤姆，你认为这种情绪有多大程度是普遍存在的？我的意思是，这在多大程度上是他个人的怨气（因为他的祖国驻扎了美军，且他对美国抱有这种敌意），而在多大程度上是更广泛的普遍群情激愤？即美军——作为西方现代性的化身——竟然在守护着圣地，诸如此类。我认为这是一种……
And that's essentially what bin Laden sets himself to do. But I think that bin Laden is expressive of a whole trend within Islamic militancy, which sees a need to respond to Westernization, let's call it that, Westernization, by looking back to the example of the prophet and his companions, so the Salafists. And this Salafist tradition then fuses with a Jihadi tradition. And the Jihadi tradition is the idea that you best serve God by fighting to maintain the dignity,
余烬确实是滚烫的，它们完全可以被煽风点火。这基本上就是本·拉登着手去做的事情。但我认为，本·拉登代表了伊斯兰激进主义中的整个潮流，他们认为有必要通过回顾先知及其同伴的榜样——也就是萨拉菲派——来应对西方化（我们姑且称之为西方化）。而这种萨拉菲传统随后与圣战主义传统融合在了一起。圣战主义传统的核心理念是：通过奋战来维护真主的尊严，
indeed the power of his dispensation. So Salafi jihadism is a trend that has, you know, it's a kind of movement. It's a way of seeing the world that has been kind of bubbling away below the surface. And the thing is that the West is not looking at this. Its eye has been fixed on the Cold War for so long. And even after the fall of the Berlin Wall, it can't take this stuff seriously. Because people getting cross about
甚至是维护真主律法的权威，才是对真主最好的侍奉。因此，萨拉菲圣战主义是一种潮流，你知道，它是一种运动。它是一种看世界的视角，一直隐隐在水面下涌动。问题在于，西方根本没有注意到这一点。它的目光长期锁定在冷战上。甚至在柏林墙倒塌之后，它也无法认真看待这些东西。因为有人会因为
American troops being present in Arabia because the prophet had said that no Christians or Jews should be allowed into Arabia seems mad to Americans. Likewise, bin Laden is terribly upset about the end of the caliphate. So after 9-11, he issues a statement and he says, what America is tasting now is something insignificant compared to what we, i.e. Muslims, have tasted for scores of years. Our nation has been tasting this humiliation and degradation for more than 80 years. And he's talking there about the ending of the caliphate, which was the end of the Ottoman Empire. Now, this is not the kind of stuff that in Langley,
美军驻扎在阿拉伯半岛而感到愤怒——因为先知曾说过不应允许任何基督徒或犹太人进入阿拉伯半岛——这在美国人看来简直是疯了。同样地，本·拉登对哈里发制度的终结感到痛心疾首。所以在9·11之后，他发表了一声明，他说：美国现在所品尝到的，同我们（即穆斯林）几十年来所品尝的相比，简直微不足道。我们的民族品尝这种羞辱和堕落已经超过80年了。他这里谈论的是哈里发制度的终结，也就是奥斯曼帝国的终结。现在，这可不是兰利、
anyone in CIA is taking seriously at all, or in MI5 or in the French security services or anything like that. But Tom, there is a sense in America, though, that there has been a growing sense, I think, since the Iranian revolution and America's humiliation and the hostage crisis at the end of the 1970s into 1980, that there was a new enemy, as it were, awakening. So this is a very strange thing to talk about in a podcast about 9-11. But we watched The Naked Gun the other day, you know, the Leslie Nielsen film. And the beginning of that is a scene in which the hero,
中央情报局的任何人，或者军情五处、法国安全服务机构之类的人会认真对待的事情。但汤姆，美国国内有一种感觉，我认为自伊朗革命以及20世纪70年代末到1980年美国的受辱和人质危机以来，这种感觉一直在增长：仿佛有一个新的敌人正在觉醒。所以这是一件在关于9·11的播客中谈论起来非常奇怪的事情。但我们前几天看了《白头神探》（The Naked Gun），你知道，由莱斯利·尼尔森主演的那部电影。电影的开场是一个场景：英雄
Frank Drebin, he bursts in and all America's enemies are gathered in a room. Now, Gorbachev is there, but he's not the chairman. The chair of the meeting is the Ayatollah Khamenei. And the other people around the room are Yasser Arafat. I mean, Idi Amin is there, bizarrely. So Yasser Arafat is there. Saddam Hussein is there, bizarrely. So Yasser Arafat is there. Saddam Hussein is there? I'm not sure if Saddam Hussein is there.
弗兰克·德雷宾（Frank Drebin）闯了进去，美国所有的敌人都聚集在一个房间里。现在，戈尔巴乔夫也在那里，但他不是主席。会议的主席是阿亚图拉哈梅内伊。房间里的其他人还有亚西尔·阿拉法特。我的意思是，伊迪·阿明也在那里，这太离奇了。所以亚西尔·阿拉法特在那里。萨达姆·侯赛因也在那里，这太离奇了。所以亚西尔·阿拉法特在那里。萨达姆·侯赛因在那里吗？我不太确定萨达姆·侯赛因是否在那里。
Kind of Gaddafi is there. I think because when it was made, late 80s, Gaddafi was loomed larger in the Western consciousness as a hate figure than Saddam Hussein did, actually, because, of course, Libya had been involved in sponsoring terrorism and so on. And it happens in the Middle East as well. I think it happens in the scene set in Morocco or somewhere. Or Beirut, sorry. It's in Beirut, isn't it happens in the Middle East as well. I think it happens in, the scene is set in Morocco or somewhere,
卡扎菲也在那里。我想是因为这部电影拍摄于80年代末，在西方人的意识中，卡扎菲作为一个令人厌恶的人物，其形象比萨达姆·侯赛因更为庞大，实际上是因为利比亚曾卷入资助恐怖主义等活动。而且这种事也发生在别处，在中东。我想这个场景设定在摩洛哥某个地方，或者贝鲁特，抱歉。是在贝鲁特，不是吗？是在贝鲁特发生在中东的。我想这个场景设定在摩洛哥某处，
or Beirut, sorry, it's in Beirut. It's Beirut, isn't it? Yeah. It is in Beirut. So there's already a sense there that the Cold War is being, I mean, it's such a strange thing to allude to, but the Cold War is being shuffled off stage
或者贝鲁特，抱歉，是在贝鲁特。是在贝鲁特，对吧？是的。确实是在贝鲁特。所以当时就已经有一种感觉：冷战正在被……我的意思是，提到这个真是一件奇怪的事，但冷战正在被推向幕后，
because Gorbachev says at one point, I have the Americans believing I'm a nice guy. Whereas the others are clearly out and out villains. And there's a sort of, I think there was a growing sense in the 1990s you see this in so many hollywood films that the neck the new threat was going to come from the middle east and from islamic fundamentalism don't you think so all that sort of samuel huntingdon stuff the clash of civilizations for example but not not not quite in the in the way that the salafi jihadists embody it because because the thing you know gaddafi is i mean his relationship to islam is very ambivalent
因为戈尔巴乔夫在某个时刻说：“我让美国人相信我是个好人。”而其他人显然是彻头彻尾的恶棍。并且有一种……我认为在20世纪90年代，人们越来越有这种感觉——你在许多好莱坞电影中都能看到这一点——新的威胁将来自中东和伊斯兰原教旨主义，你不这么认为吗？所以所有那些塞缪尔·亨廷顿的论调，例如文明的冲突。但并非完全以萨拉菲圣战分子所体现的那种方式，因为你知道，卡扎菲——我的意思是，他与伊斯兰教的关系非常矛盾。
yes of course yeah there's this kind of bartist tradition which is basically kind of you know i mean it's bartism is fact which is the ideology of of saddam hussein and of the asads in syria well that's about modern modern, isn't it? Yeah. That's founded by a Christian. So that's a kind of sinister fascist... I mean, basically, there's more to fascism than it does to Islam. Ayatollah Khomeini, he's a Shiite. And so Shiism is not missionary in the way that Sunniism is. So these are kind of the two great traditions within Islam. What bin Laden brings to the imagination, and I think you're actually right to frame it in terms of Hollywood, because this is an influence on how the Americans understand 9-11. But it's also,
是的，当然。有一种复兴社会党传统，基本上是……我的意思是，复兴社会党主义实际上是萨达姆·侯赛因和叙利亚阿萨德家族的意识形态。那关于现代性，对吧？是的。那是和一个基督徒创立的。所以那是一种邪恶的法西斯主义……我的意思是，基本上，法西斯主义的成分比伊斯兰教的成分更多。阿亚图拉霍梅尼是一个什叶派。因此，什叶派不像逊尼派那样具有传教性。所以这些是伊斯兰教内部的两大传统。本·拉登带给人们想象力的东西——而且我认为你确实有理由用好莱坞的视角来界定它，因为这确实影响了美国人如何理解9·11。但它也是……
I mean, it's an influence on how Bin Laden comes to imagine attacking the trade center, because in the training camps, most of the people who are going there, they're kind of deracinated. They're people from often very westernized. They're kind of younger sons of wealthy families like Bin Laden himself. They're often English speaking. These are very, very kind of internationalist camps. And in the evenings after they've done their training and their indoctrination and everything, they will sit down and they will watch Hollywood films. They're kind of big fans of Schwarzenegger and all that kind of stuff. Yeah, it's fascinating.
我的意思是，它也影响了本·拉登如何构想袭击世贸中心，因为在训练营里，去那里的绝大多数人其实都已经失去了根基。他们往往是非常西方化的人。他们通常是像本·拉登本人那样来自富裕家庭的幼子。他们通常会说英语。这些是非常非常国际化的营地。每天傍晚，当他们完成训练、洗脑和所有这些之后，他们会坐下来观看好莱坞电影。他们是施瓦辛格等人的狂热粉丝。是的，这太迷人了。
And so what 9-11 does is to cast Bin Laden actually as a kind of Bond villain. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. In his cave network, his base. I remember all those illustrations in the newspapers claiming that this was this incredibly sophisticated bunker. The Ayatollah or Gaddafi or Idi Amin or I suppose Kim Jong-un in, what was it, the puppet one? Team America. Team America. I mean, these are all baddies who are leaders of countries. Bin Laden is stateless. Bin Laden has had his Saudi passport taken away from him. And that's what makes him such a kind of ideal figure to play the role of a Bond villain. And you're right about that. So when after 9-11, the Americans and NATO attack Afghanistan and they move into the Tora Bora mountains, and Bin Laden and al-Qaeda are hiding out in caves.
所以9·11事件实际上把本·拉登塑造成了一个邦德式的反派。是的，我认为完全正确。在他的山洞网络和基地里。我还记得报纸上的那些插图，宣称这是一个极其复杂的地下掩体。阿亚图拉、卡扎菲、伊迪·阿明，或者我想象中的金正恩，在哪个电影里来着？《美国战队：世界警察》（Team America）。我的意思是，这些都是身为国家元首的坏蛋。而本·拉登是无国籍的。本·拉登的沙特护照被没收了。正因如此，他才成为了扮演邦德式反派的理想人物。你说的没错。因此，在9·11之后，美国和北约进攻阿富汗，进入托拉博拉山区，本·拉登和基地组织藏身于山洞中。
And I remember there was a kind of picture in the Sunday Times of this cave complex. They didn't actually say it had swimming pools, but they might as well have done. It was entirely fabricated from someone who'd been watching James Bond films. It's Blofeld's base, basically, isn't it? Yes, absolutely. And there was all this kind of talk about how they were fighting their way through cave complexes and things. Absolute rubbish. You know, there were no cave complexes.
我记得《星期日泰晤士报》上刊登了一张这个山洞综合体的照片。他们虽然没明说里面有游泳池，但也差不离了。这完全是一个看过詹姆斯·邦德电影的人凭空捏造出来的。这基本上就是布洛菲德（Blofeld）的基地，对吧？是的，完全如此。当时到处都在谈论他们如何在山洞综合体中浴血奋战之类的话。简直一派胡言。你知道，根本没有什么山洞综合体。
There was none of it. It was just a load of caves. But that kind of internationalism, you know, both sides saw the other as the embodiment of a kind of sinister and terrifying conspiracy to take over the world and destroy everything that was good. So Bin Laden is talking about good and evil. He's talking about God and Satan. And Bush, likewise, in the aftermath of 9-11, is talking about good and evil. Axis of evil.
根本没有这回事。那只是一堆山洞而已。但那种国际主义（你知道的），双方都把对方视为一种阴险而可怕的阴谋的化身，这个阴谋企图统治世界并摧毁一切美好的事物。所以本·拉登在谈论善与恶。他在谈论上帝与撒旦。同样地，布什在9·11事件发生后，也在谈论善与恶。邪恶轴心。
Yes, exactly. Exactly. And I think you're absolutely right about the internationalism of the sort of al-Qaeda recruits. I mean, Mohammed Atta, for example, he was the chief hijacker. He was the oldest. He was, yeah, he'd studied urban planning. Egyptian from Hamburg.
没错，正是如此。没错。而且我认为你对基地组织新兵的国际主义倾向的看法绝对正确。我的意思是，比如穆罕默德·阿塔（Mohammed Atta），他是首席劫机者。他是年龄最大的一个。他曾学习过城市规划。他是来自汉堡的埃及人。
Exactly. He'd studied urban planning in Hamburg. This extraordinary story, I'm not sure how true this is, that his parents or his father had overheard two Germans speaking on holiday in Egypt and had spoken to them and had talked to them. And they turned out to be running a sort of exchange scheme. And he said, oh, you know,
没错。他在汉堡学习城市规划。这是一个非凡的故事，我不太确定这有多真实：他的父母，或者说他的父亲，在埃及度假时无意中听到两个德国人在说话，于是便和他们交谈起来。结果发现他们正在经营某种交换生计划。然后他说：“哦，你知道吗，
my son's really interested in urban planning. Can he come to? And he goes off to Germany. And it's that classic thing, which you also see with Said Qutub, who's one of the sort of, arguably the sort of founding father of modern Islamic militancy, isn't he?
我儿子对城市规划很感兴趣。他能去吗？”于是他就去了德国。这就是那种经典的模式——你在赛义德·库特布（Said Qutub）身上也能看到，他可以说是现代伊斯兰激进主义的奠基人之一，不是吗？
That of the sort of the guy who's been uprorooted he's gone to the sort of modern western country and he's lonely miserable um people aren't you know friendly to him people are mean to him and he feels left out and that resentment grows and grows and builds and builds and you see that pattern don't you again and again um in the profiles of the of some of these people involved in the story. Well, I mean, I think it's interesting. So Atta is Egyptian. Zahiri, who is bin Laden's number two. I think he's still currently... He's still out there.
一个背井离乡的人，他去了某个现代西方国家，感到孤独、悲惨……人们对（他）并不友好，人们对他很刻薄，他觉得自己被冷落了，这种怨恨与日俱增、不断累积。你会在这个故事中某些涉事人员的个人资料里，一次又一次地看到这种模式。好吧，我的意思是，我觉得很有意思。阿塔是埃及人。扎瓦赫里（Zahiri）是本·拉登的二把手。我想他现在依然……他还活着。
He's still out there. He's in Al-Qaeda, isn't he? Somewhere. He knows where he is. I mean, he's Egyptian. He was a surgeon, got involved in the assassination of President Sadat in 1981. Sadat, of course, having signed
他还活着。他还在基地组织里，对吧？在某个地方。他知道自己在哪里。我的意思是，他是埃及人。他曾是一名外科医生，卷入了1981年暗杀萨达特总统的事件。萨达特当然是因为签署了
the peace concord with Israel. So that was his crime. And you mentioned Saeed Khattoub, who was a kind of stoop-shouldered, balding, very shy Egyptian who goes in the aftermath of the, of the second world war to America, to New York, to Washington. And then to this town in, in Colorado, which was kind of temp founded by temperance. So it's, I mean,
与以色列的和平协议而成了罪人。这就是他的罪名。你提到了赛义德·库特布，他是一个肩膀微驼、秃顶、非常害羞的埃及人，在第二次世界大战结束后前往美国，去往纽约、华盛顿。然后去了科罗拉多州的那个小镇，该镇由禁酒主义者建立。所以，我的意思是，
it's very, very straight laced, but he regarded it as absolutely Solomon Gamora and was, was kind of obsessed by the, the lewdness of American women and all kinds of things. He wrote lots of weird stuff about their buttocks and stuff. Clearly, there's a lot going on in his subconscious. Yeah, and so I think that with Egypt,
那里非常非常古板守旧，但他却将其视作绝对的所多玛和蛾摩拉，并对美国女性的淫荡以及诸如此类的事情着迷不已。他写了许多关于她们臀部之类的古怪东西。很明显，他的潜意识里有很多压抑的东西。是的，所以我觉得对于埃及来说，
so this is all coming off the backdrop. This is why I want to do Napoleon in Egypt, because, of course, Egypt is the first target, really, for the modern West. Napoleon conquers it, then the British inherit it. And I think that for Egyptians, Cairo, the great cultural centre of Islam in its golden ages, to go from the chaos of Cairo, the poverty of Cairo, to American cities in the 50s, to Hamburg in the 90s to study town planning. You feel a sense of kind of humiliation, I think. And that's evident in Kutub and I think it's evident in Atta.
这一切都有其背景。这就是为什么我想做“拿破仑在埃及”这一期，因为埃及确实是现代西方的第一个目标。拿破仑征服了它，随后英国人接管了它。我认为对于埃及人来说，开罗作为伊斯兰教在其黄金时代的伟大文化中心，从开罗的混乱和贫困，到50年代的美国城市，再到90年代去汉堡学习城市规划，你会感到一种屈辱感，我认为。这在库特布身上显而易见，我认为在阿塔身上也显而易见。
And I think also, I mean, I don't want to kind of do cod psychology, but there is a kind of sexual dimension to it as well, because both Kutub and Atta are obsessed by the easy availability of sex in Western cities. And Mohammed Atta, in his will, leaves this kind of weird prescriptions that no pregnant women will attend his funeral procession and no women will be allowed to visit his grave or anything like that. Well, Atta had stayed in Hamburg before he goes to America to carry out the deed. He's been staying with a family who had a daughter who was unmarried but had a baby. And they kicked him out, I think, eventually because he treated her with such contempt.
而且我也认为——我不想搞什么庸俗的心理分析——这里面也有某种性方面的维度，因为库特布和阿塔都对西方城市里唾手可得的性爱着迷不已。穆罕默德·阿塔在他的遗嘱中留下了这种奇怪的规定：不准任何孕妇参加他的葬礼游行，也不准任何女性去他的墓地参观之类。好吧，阿塔在去美国执行任务之前曾逗留汉堡。他一直寄宿在一个家庭里，该家庭有一个未婚生子但没有结婚的女儿。我想他们最终把他赶了出来，因为他极其轻蔑地对待她。
And this girl and her baby, this young woman and her baby, played a massive part in his imagination as sort of symbols of Western decadence. And I don't think you have to go too deep into the world of court psychology to see that there is something kind of weird going on in his mind there. And so Kutub writes these texts that really kind of are the match that lights the kind of blaze that Bin Laden will then kind of really blow up. That's a terrible metaphor but yeah sometimes um and he he he is basically saying
这个女孩和她的孩子——这个年轻女子和她的孩子——在他的想象中扮演了极其重要的角色，成为西方堕落的象征。我不认为你必须深入庸俗心理学的世界，就能看出他脑子里正发生着某种诡异的事情。所以库特布写下的这些文本，真的就像是点燃了一场熊熊烈火的火柴，而本·拉登随后将这场烈火煽得更旺。这是一个糟糕的比喻，但是……是的，有时……他基本上是在说：
we have to turn our backs on this and we have to to look back to the example of the prophet and islam is it is only islam that can save not just muslims but the whole of humanity so it it is you know the stakes could not be higher and in a way way, you know, in a sense, Bush is the same. And that's what makes, it's not 9-11 itself that is particularly important. Shocking though it is, you know, overwhelming, it's the reactions to it. Okay, well, that's a perfect point to take a break. And then we'll come back and we should talk about George W. Bush and the reaction to 9-11. See you in a minute.
我们必须背离这一切，我们必须回顾先知和伊斯兰教的榜样，只有伊斯兰教才能拯救不仅是穆斯林，还有全人类；所以，你知道，赌注再高不过了。某种程度上，你知道，从某种意义上说，布什也是如此。这也就是为什么——并非9·11事件本身特别重要（尽管它令人震惊、压倒一切）——而是对此的反应（才是关键）。好吧，这是个暂停的绝佳时机。然后我们将回来，讨论乔治·W·布什以及对9·11的反应。一会儿见。
Hello. Excuse the brief interruption. We'll soon have you back in the warm embrace of Tom Holland and Dominic Sandbrook. But first, we wanted to tell you about our new podcast, Tommy's and Jerry's, which explores the relationship between Britain and Germany through history to the present. It features me, Oliver Moody, a Briton based in Berlin, and Katja Hoyer, a German historian, mostly enjoying life in England. Here's a brief taster. Break out the beach towels and bag the best spot. Welcome to Tommies and Jerrys, a new podcast in which we plan to put the Realpolitik and the Eröffnungsdiskussionsorgien into the world of podcasting.
你好。打扰大家一小会儿。我们很快就会让你回到汤姆·霍兰和多米尼克·桑德布鲁克温暖的怀抱中。但在那之前，我们想向你介绍我们的新播客《汤米与杰瑞》（Tommy's and Jerry's），该节目探讨了从历史到现在的英国与德国之间的关系。节目由我——常驻柏林的英国人奥利弗·穆迪（Oliver Moody），以及卡佳·霍耶（Katja Hoyer）共同主持，她是一位主要在英国享受生活的德国历史学家。以下是一个简短的预告。带上沙滩巾，抢占最好的位置。欢迎收听《汤米与杰瑞》，这是一档全新的播客，在节目中我们计划将现实政治（Realpolitik）和侃大山（Eröffnungsdiskussionsorgien）带入播客世界。
Each week we'll discuss the past and present of Anglo-German relations. What makes us different? And what makes us sometimes painfully similar? There's a very famous picture of Thatcher driving along in a Challenger tank with a British flag flying and she's got her goggles on and her scarf. She looks like the absolute warrior queen, almost like a Britannia-style nationalistic figure. But when you look at the zoomed-out version of that photo,
每周我们将探讨英德关系的过去与现在。是什么让我们与众不同？又是什么让我们有时痛苦地相似？有一张非常著名的照片，撒切尔夫人驾驶着一辆挑战者坦克在路上行驶，上面飘扬着英国国旗，她戴着护目镜和围巾。她看起来就像绝对的女战士女王，几乎像个不列颠风格的民族主义偶像。但如果你看那张照片拉远后的版本，
it was actually taken on a British military base in West Germany. And right next to her, there's Cole trundling along on his own Leopard 2 German battle tank with a German flag. And it was clearly some effort to try and give them like a fun day out together. And all that is remembered for is just this symbol of British nationalism. Yeah, and that's probably exactly how she would have liked it as well. Things have got so bad that there's this paper that turned up showing that Cole had made a formal request not to talk to Thatcher anymore, and to talk to the Foreign Secretary, Douglas Heard, instead. And Thatcher had just scribbled on it in massive capital letter handwriting, no! Because they made no effort to hide that either. Thatcher in particular was kind of
它实际上是在西德的一个英国军事基地拍摄的。就在她旁边，科尔正开着他自己的豹2型德国主战坦克笨拙地驶过，上面插着德国国旗。这显然是试图让他们一起度过一个有趣的郊游日。而这一切被人们记住的，仅仅是英国民族主义的象征。是的，这可能也正是她所希望的。事情已经糟到出现了一份文件，显示科尔曾正式请求不再与撒切尔夫人交谈，而是转而与外交大臣道格拉斯·赫德（Douglas Hurd）交谈。而撒切尔夫人在文件上用巨大的全大写字母潦草地写着：不！因为他们甚至没有试图掩饰这一点。尤其是撒切尔夫人，一直是……
openly hostile. You see that on all of the photographs. I don't think they ever had as bad a relationship as people made it out to be, to be honest, Boris Johnson and Angela Merkel. You don't see Boris slapping Angie on the back, but you do get the sense from the last visit that there was a genuine effort. I'm not so sure. I've been told in Berlin that actually it's terrible. It's really, really bad. And she can't stand him.
公开表现出敌意。你在所有的照片中都能看到这一点。说实话，我不认为鲍里斯·约翰逊和安格拉·默克尔之间的关系像人们想象的那样糟糕。你不会看到鲍里斯拍安吉的背，但从最近的访问中，你能感觉到双方确实做出了真诚的努力。我可不这么认为。我在柏林听说情况其实很糟糕。真的、真的很糟糕。她简直无法忍受他。
That's it for this week. Thank you for listening to Tommies and Jerrys. Search for Tommies and Jerrys wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. podcasts. early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking about 9-11, the attacks on the World Trade Centre and on Washington DC That happened exactly 20 years ago. Tom, there was a documentary on the BBC a couple of nights ago, absolutely brilliant documentary about George W. Bush and sort of taking you through minute by minute his reaction as the day unfolded.
本周节目就到这里。感谢收听《汤米与杰瑞》。在各大播客平台搜索《汤米与杰瑞》即可收听。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐之余》。播客。抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在讨论9·11事件，即世贸中心和华盛顿特区遭受的袭击。那是整整20年前发生的。汤姆，前几天晚上BBC播出了一个纪录片，关于乔治·W·布什的一部极其精彩的纪录片，带你一分钟一分钟地回顾了他在事件发生当天的反应。
You saw it, didn't you? I did. The guy who made it, Adam Wishart. Friend of yours. Old friend. Everybody's a friend of Tom Holland. A fantastic film. Yeah.
你看过，对吧？我看过。制作这部纪录片的人是亚当·威夏特（Adam Wishart）。你的朋友。老朋友。汤姆·霍兰的朋友遍天下。一部出色的电影。是的。
And how charming they all seemed. Well, this is the extraordinary thing. These people who, I mean, if you move as we do in kind of literary media sort of circles in Britain. I mean, all these people are reviled, you know, to a degree that, I mean, this sounds like an absurd thing to say, but I've heard people slagging off George W. Bush far more often than I've heard them slagging off Osama bin Laden. But he came across as, in that documentary, as remarkably human.
他们看起来都那么迷人。好吧，这就是非凡之处。这些人——我的意思是，如果你像我们一样在英国的文学媒体圈子中活动。我的意思是，所有人都在痛骂这些人，程度之深……这听起来可能是一件荒谬的话题，但我听到有人抨击乔治·W·布什的频率，远比听到他们抨击本·拉登的频率要高得多。但在这部纪录片中，他表现得异常人性化。
But the reason for that is that we're judging him by our standards yeah of course and what i would say about bush is that what he did was far worse than anything that trump did right biden i i think i think he trashed the american brand and the western brand okay well let's come back to that in a sec i think there's i think as i think bin laden I think he trashed the American brand and the Western brand. Okay. Well, let's come back to that in a sec. As I think bin Laden trashed the Islamic brand. So one of the things that I think has come out of 9-11 is that the global reputation of both Islam and the West has been seriously damaged. Well, Islam and also specifically America, Tom.
但原因在于我们是用我们的标准在评判他，对吧，当然。我对布什的评价是，他所做的事比特朗普做过的任何事都要糟糕得多。没错，拜登……我真的认为他毁了美国的品牌和西方的品牌。好吧，我们待会儿再谈这个。我认为，正如我所认为的本·拉登一样，我认为他毁了美国的品牌和西方的品牌。好吧，我们稍后再谈这个。正如我认为本·拉登毁了伊斯兰教的品牌一样。所以我觉得9·11带来的后果之一，就是伊斯兰教和西方的全球声誉都受到了严重损害。不仅是伊斯兰教，还有特别是美国，汤姆。
I think Britain as well. There were, oh, I don't know, Britain. There were, you know, there's all this amazing footage after 9-11 of Vladimir Putin lighting candles, people around the world uniting in support, playing the American National Anthem, waving American flags. In the days after the event. Not everywhere, of course.
我觉得英国也是。当时有——哦，我不知道，英国也是。当时，你知道，9·11事件发生后，有大量精彩的画面：弗拉基米尔·普京在点蜡烛，世界各地的人们团结起来表示支持，演奏美国国歌，挥舞美国国旗。在事件发生后的几天里。当然，并非所有地方都这样。
I mean, not in Ramallah, but worldwide, and obviously especially in Europe. And in a way, that seems odd now because the reaction against America was so quick after the invasion of Iraq, what, two years later, wasn't it? But the thing is watching that documentary. So George Bush had only been in office since January. And he'd come into office as, I mean, the documentary, he says this specifically, I came in as a domestic president, which I remember at
我的意思是，拉姆安拉没有，但在世界范围内，显然尤其是在欧洲。从某种程度上看，现在回想起来这似乎很奇怪，因为两年后美国入侵伊拉克时，对美国的反对情绪来得是那么迅猛，不是吗？但问题是，看了那部纪录片——乔治·布什当时从一月份才开始上台执政。他上台时的愿望是——我的意思是，纪录片里他明确说过这一点——我上台时是一个内政总统，这让我想起
the time because I was in America during that election campaign. And he said again and again, the US is no longer going to be the world's policeman. So he wanted, you know, he was preaching an antidote to what he saw as Clinton's interventionism in Somalia and his drone and his airstrikes and these kinds of things. Bush said, we're not going to do that anymore. And then the documentary captures very well the fact that in just a few hours, Bush's whole sense of himself and his role in history changes.
当时的情景，因为那场竞选期间我正好在美国。他一再重申，美国将不再充当世界的警察。所以他希望，你知道，他宣称这是一剂解药，用来对付他眼中的克林顿在索马里的干涉主义、无人机空袭以及诸如此类的事情。布什说，我们再也不会那样做了。然后纪录片非常精彩地捕捉到了这样一个事实：仅仅几个小时内，布什对自己以及自己在历史上的角色的全部认识就发生了改变。
You know, there's that famous footage. He's reading books, isn't he, with a kind of primary school class? About a goat, I think. Yeah, they're doing spelling. And the footage is amazing. You know, they go in on his eyes, and you see the flicker in his eyes when he's told. He doesn't rush off because he doesn't want to scare the children.
你知道，有那个著名的镜头。他当时在读一本书，对吧，是在一个小学班级里？好像是关于一只山羊的书。对，他们正在拼写。那个镜头太精彩了。你看他的特写镜头，当他被告知消息时，你能看到他眼神中的闪烁。他没有急忙离开，因为他不想吓到孩子们。
But, you know, within hours, his sense of who he is and what he is for has changed and I actually thought what that documentary captured and this is why the assassination of Franz Ferdinand seems to me a reasonable parallel is the extent to which he's the prisoner of events as well as their master
但是，你知道，在几个小时之内，他对自己是谁以及他存在的意义的理解都改变了。其实我觉得那部纪录片所捕捉到的东西——这也是为什么弗兰茨·斐迪南大公遇刺在我看来是一个合理的类比——在于他既是历史事件的掌握者，在很大程度上同时也是事件的阶下囚。
so he says he knew what the American people expected and there's a moment at the end of the documentary when he's talking to firefighters and made the wreckage of the World Trade Center. And what people forget is that he, and he says this himself, is he starts off talking about praying and sort of sorrow and coming together and stuff.
所以他说他知道美国人民期望什么。纪录片快结束时有一个片段，当时他正在与消防员交谈，身处世界贸易中心的废墟之中。人们往往忘记的是，他——他自己也这么说——一开始是谈论祈祷、悲伤以及团结之类的事情。
And he says in the documentary, I could see they didn't want to hear that. You know, I was an experienced politician. I could read the crowd. What they wanted to hear was, we're going to go and, you know, kick their ass, which is basically what he says at the end. And what he did. And what he did, he changes his tone. But the question, I suppose, is, would any American president have behaved differently at the end of this period of when they thought their top nation of great, buoyant American
他在纪录片里说，我看出他们不想听这些。你知道，我是一个经验丰富的政治家。我能看懂群众的心思。他们想听的是，我们要去，你知道，狠狠地教训他们一顿——这基本上就是他在最后说的话。而他也确实这么做了。而他也确实这么做了，他改变了语气。但问题是，我想，在这个盛极一时、充满生气的美国
exceptionalism? I mean, the gap between them and the rest of the world militarily is probably greater in 2001 than ever before or since, because China has yet to fully rearm as it has now. Could anybody have resisted that, Tom? I mean, they were always going to go into Afghanistan, weren't they? I think going into Afghanistan was inevitable. I think I don't see any way in which, I agree, no American president could not have done that.
例外论时期结束之际，换作任何一个美国总统，在那个时刻的行为都会有所不同吗？我的意思是，在2001年，他们与世界其他国家在军事力量上的差距可能比以往任何时候都要大，因为中国当时尚未像现在这样全面重新武装。任何人都能抵挡得住那种冲动吗，汤姆？我的意思是，他们本来就注定要进入阿富汗，不是吗？我认为进入阿富汗是不可避免的。我觉得我想象不出任何一个美国总统会不这么做。
I think the wrong turn was what happened after afghanistan which essentially is is iraq yeah and you know there are two i guess there are kind of two takes on iraq as why the americans go into iraq one one is the kind of bleakly cynical one that it's all about oil or israel or vengeance for you know saddam hussein being horrid to George Bush's dad or whatever. And the other is that it was a necessary step in the war on terror and that it was a welcome chance to overthrow a kind of horrible tyrant in the form of Saddam Hussein. And of course, I mean, it could be both and probably was both,
我认为走错的方向是阿富汗战争之后发生的事情，基本上就是伊拉克，对吧。你知道，关于美国人为什么要打伊拉克，我想大致有两种看法。一种是相当冷酷愤世嫉俗的看法，认为这全是为了石油、以色列，或者是为了给萨达姆·侯赛因曾对乔治·布什的父亲做出无礼举动之类的事情复仇。另一种看法则认为，这是反恐战争中必要的一步，是一个推翻萨达姆·侯赛因这类可怕暴君的绝佳机会。当然，我的意思是，这两种因素可能兼而有之，而且很可能确实两者皆有，
all kinds of different interests kind of mixing and merging. And we know, we talked about this dawning sense on his face that he is someone who has been put at a pivotal moment in history and his decisions are going to count. I think he feels that he's been put there by God. He is a deeply, deeply believing Christian. And I think that he believes when he talks about good and evil, that the war on terror, you know, it could have been a police operation, but it isn't. And, you know, the operations, you know, it's kind of operation enduring freedom. The original name for war on terror is going to be Operation Infinite Justice. This is a crusade. You know, he used the word crusade and then got kind of told off by his advisors because this wasn't advisable.
各种不同的利益在其中交织融合。我们知道，我们之前谈到过他脸上的那种顿悟，意识到自己正处于历史的关键时刻，而他的决定将产生重大影响。我想他觉得自己是被上帝放在那个位置上的。他是一个极其虔诚的基督徒。我认为当他谈论善与恶时，他相信反恐战争——你知道，这本可以是一场警察行动，但事实并非如此。而且，你知道，这些行动，你知道，这就是所谓的“持久自由行动”。反恐战争最初的名字本该是“无限正义行动”。这是一场十字军东征。你知道，他用了“十字军东征”这个词，结果被他的顾问们训斥了一顿，因为这并不明智。
But it was a crusade in exactly the same way as bin Laden, likewise, sees himself as embroiled in a fight for good and evil. And the thing that complicates it with Bush, and of course with Blair as well, is that they never frame it in overtly Christian terms, even though everyone knows that this is where they're coming from. Instead, what they do, and again, I think this is entirely, you know, I don't think they're lying about this, but Bush repeatedly says about bin Laden and Al-Qaeda that they're corrupting
但这确实是一场十字军东征，正如本·拉登同样认为自己卷入了一场善恶之争一样。让布什（当然还有布莱尔）的情况变得复杂的是，他们从不以公开的基督教术语来定性这场战争，尽管大家都知道他们的立场根源于此。相反，他们所做的——而且再次说明，我认为这完全是，你知道，我不认为他们在撒谎——布什一再声称本·拉登和基地组织正在腐蚀
Islam, that they don't really understand Islam, that they haven't got it right. And that basically Islam is entirely compatible with Western liberal democracy. Blair said that. I mean, every Western leader said that in the aftermath of 9-11 for very understandable reasons, because they didn't want to provoke kind of anti-Muslim feeling within the West itself or indeed beyond. But I think the problem with that was that it was a kind of cultural arrogance because it suggested everything that bin Laden was terrified about. It was suggesting precisely that yes, Islam, this ancient sophisticated civilization can absolutely just be folded into the more of Hamburg town planning or sex clubs or whatever, that it's just another kind of interesting local detail. and that essentially the morals and
伊斯兰教，他们并不真正理解伊斯兰教，他们没有搞懂其真谛。并且基本上伊斯兰教与西方自由民主是完全相容的。布莱尔也这么说过。我的意思是，在9·11事件之后，出于完全可以理解的原因，每一个西方领导人都这么说过，因为他们不想在西方社会内部甚至外部激起反穆斯林的情绪。但我认为其中的问题在于，这是一种文化傲慢，因为它暗示了所有让本·拉登感到恐惧的事情。这恰恰在暗示，是的，伊斯兰教这样一个古老而复杂的文明，完全可以被轻而易举地折叠进汉堡镇规划、性俱乐部之类的模子里，暗示它只不过是一个有趣的当地小细节，
the values of humanity are equivalent to those of Westerners at the beginning of the 21st century. Well, that's all that sort of stuff about fighting for enlightenment values, isn't it? Absolutely. We should export enlightenment values and that Islam can somehow be easily be folded into it, as you say. But that's not really... Bush isn't talking about enlightenment values.
并且本质上人类的道德和价值观与21世纪初西方人的道德价值观是等同的。好吧，这全都是关于为启蒙运动价值观而战的那些论调，对吧？完全正确。我们应该输出启蒙运动的价值观，并认为伊斯兰教可以以某种方式轻而易举地融入其中，正如你所说的那样。但事实并非如此……布什谈论的并不是启蒙运动的价值观。
He's talking about rights. He's talking about freedoms. He's talking about freedoms. You know, he's saying, why do they hate us? They hate us for our freedom. Yeah. But these are very, very culturally specific American perspectives. See, I take on Bush would be slightly different in that I think straight away Bush transforms himself into an unashamed American nationalist. And, you know, I think of things like, you know, the Patriot Act, which is the act that enshrines surveillance.
他谈论的是权利。他谈论的是自由。他谈论的是自由。你知道，他在说，为什么他们恨我们？他们恨我们的自由。是的。但这些是非常、非常具有文化特异性的美国视角。你看，我对布什的看法可能略有不同，我认为布什立刻将自己转变成了一个毫不掩饰的美国民族主义者。而且，你知道，我想到了诸如《爱国者法案》之类的东西，这部法案将监控体制化。
The Department of Homeland Security. I always found that such a jarring name because I always thought when people talk about the homeland, I mean, something that we in Britain would never do. I mean, it's impossible to, isn't it? Well, at least, I mean, maybe they've got one, God almighty. I mean, it's impossible to. Isn't it? Well, he's did. I mean, maybe they've got one, God almighty. But, you know, that sort of rhetoric.
国土安全部。我一直觉得这个名字极其刺耳，因为每当人们谈论“国土（homeland）”这个词时——我的意思是，这是我们英国人绝对不会做的事。我的意思是，这根本不可能，不是吗？好吧，至少，我是说，也许他们有一个，全能的上帝啊。我的意思是，这不可能。不是吗？好吧，他确实这么做了。我是说，也许他们有一个，全能的上帝。但是，你知道，那种修辞。
And I think, well, to me, one of his great mistakes, apart from Iraq, obviously, was in speaking purely to a domestic American audience. And I can completely understand why he did that. I don't think he was, though. Because he's endlessly sending messages. Actually, when you look at them, how many messages, how often he talks about Islam, how often he addresses the Muslim world,
而且我想，对我来说，除了伊拉克之外，他最大的错误之一显然就是只对美国国内受众发表讲话。我完全理解他为什么要这么做。不过，我不认为他真的只是在对国内讲话。因为他不断地在发出信息。事实上，当你仔细观察时，他发送了多少信息，他谈论伊斯兰教的频率有多高，他向穆斯林世界喊话的频率有多高，
there's a lot of it. And it's all kind of character. He says, when it comes to the common rights and needs of men and women, there is no clash of civilizations. Essentially, he's saying that his understanding of what the rights and needs of men and women are are equivalent to all of humanities. And he's saying that his understanding of what the rights and needs of men and women are equivalent to all of humanities.
这其中包含了很多内容。而且这全都是关于某种特质的。他说，当谈到男人和女人的共同权利与需求时，根本不存在文明的冲突。从本质上讲，他是说他对男人和女人的权利与需求的理解与全人类是等同的。并且他在说他对男人和女人的权利与需求的理解与全人类是等同的。
I think that he does have this kind of universalist mission, as Blair did as well. It was really, really vital part of what they were about, is why they're waging a war on terror. But I think at the same time, there is incredibly chauvinist nationalist figures in his administration and you know bush is obviously a very smart astute politician but i don't think he's as smart as dick say say as dick cheney or donald rumsfeld you know vice president donald rumsfeld that the defence... You know, what do they have?
我认为他确实有这种普世主义的使命感，布莱尔也是如此。这是他们所作所为中非常、非常重要的一部分，也是他们为什么要发动反恐战争的原因。但我认为与此同时，他的政府中存在着极其沙文主义的民族主义人物，而且你知道布什显然是一个非常精明、敏锐的政治家，但我不认为他有迪克——比如迪克·切尼或唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德那么精明，你知道，副总统唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德，国防……你知道，他们担任的是什么职位？
Secretary of State for Defence? What do they call it? Yeah, Secretary of Defence. Yeah. And immense Washington veterans. I mean, they've been around since the Nixon administration. They are all about,
国防大臣？他们管这叫什么？对，国防部长。是的。他们都是华盛顿的老资历政客了。我的意思是，他们从尼克森政府时期就一直在政坛活跃。他们所关心的全都是，
you know, America first. Yes. And that kind of... That sense of a moral mission that Bush and Blair had, and that's why, you know, the Jeremy Paxman question to Blair, did he pray together, was such a... You know, I mean, it was kind of that sense of a moral mission that Bush and Blair had. And that's why, you know, the Jeremy Paxman question to Blair, did he pray together was such a, you know, I mean, it was kind of probing this absolutely neuralgics because you had no doubt that they were praying together. But the problem was that the moment they cast it as a war on terror and felt that therefore this legitimated basically kind of, you know, invading and overthrowing anybody that they wanted to. They were brought up against the fact that actually lots of people didn't want the kind of freedom that they were bringing, didn't want the kind of understanding of what was right and proper that Bush and Blair believed in.
你知道，美国优先。是的。而布什和布莱尔身上那种道德使命感，也就是为什么杰瑞米·帕克斯曼（Jeremy Paxman）质问布莱尔他们是否一起祈祷时会产生那样一种……你知道，我的意思是，这触及了那种绝对敏感的神经，因为你毫不怀疑他们确实在一起祈祷。但问题是，当他们把这场战争定性为反恐战争，并因此认为这就合法化了他们基本上想要入侵和推翻任何人的行为时，他们撞上了残酷的现实：实际上有很多人并不想要他们带来的那种自由，不想要布什和布莱尔所信仰的那种对正确与恰当事物的理解，
And therefore were going to fight back and the moment they started fighting back you know every imperial force has to has a choice do you you know do you cut and run or do you fight and the americans chose to fight and so therefore inevitably the corollary of that is that you start killing people and of course you start torturing people. And the kind of the trashing of the rule of law, the rule of international law, which is a completely Western structure. I mean, Bin Laden's right about that. Al-Zarqawi, this kind of terrifying murderous figure known as the Sheikh of Slaughterers in Iraq, who blows up weddings, slits windpipes. I mean, terrifying figure. He's absolutely committed to the idea that international law is a Western scam. It's a Christian scam. And therefore, Azekawi blows up the United Nations
因此他们将奋起反抗。而一旦他们开始反抗，你知道，任何帝国力量都面临一个选择：你是选择——你知道，你是夹着尾巴逃跑，还是选择战斗？美国人选择了战斗。所以随之而来的必然结果就是，你开始杀人，当然，你也开始虐囚。法治的践踏，国际法规则的践踏——这是一套完全西方的结构。我的意思是，本·扎卡维，这个被称为伊拉克“屠夫谢赫”的可怕而嗜杀的人物，他会炸毁婚礼现场，割断人的气管。我的意思是，这是一个极其可怕的人物。他坚信国际法是一场西方的骗局。是一场基督教的骗局。因此，扎卡维为了这个原因炸毁了巴格达的联合国总部。
in Baghdad for that reason. But this is why things like Guantanamo, the camp at Guantanamo. It's so lethal. Those horrendous pictures, Lindy, England. That was the war's name, wasn't it? The prison in Iraq that was the name, wasn't it? And the prison in Iraq, that was Iraq, wasn't it? Yes.
但这就是为什么像关塔那摩，关塔那摩集中营这样的地方。它是如此致命。那些可怕的照片，林迪·英格兰。那是那所监狱的名字，对吧？伊拉克的那座监狱就是那个名字，对吧？伊拉克的监狱，那是伊拉克，对吧？是的。
I mean, they are so damaging to the American brand. Because, you know, if you're claiming to, if you frame it in ideological, cultural terms, there's a war on terror. In other words, what you're offering is kind of virtue, peace and so on. And if you just trash that with your own activities, then it's hardly surprising that you're going to inflame people against you. But actually, Tom, before you go back, you re-embark on your fascinating lecture. I wanted to say moral mission.
我的意思是，这些对美国品牌的打击太大了。因为，你知道，如果你声称要……如果你用意识形态、文化术语来界定它，说这是一场反恐战争。换句话说，你所提供的是某种美德、和平等等。而如果你用自己的实际行动把这一切践踏得粉碎，那么你激起人们对你的敌意也就不足为奇了。不过说真的，汤姆，在你回去之前，在你重新开始你那迷人的演讲之前，我想说的是道德使命感。
That sense of moral mission, I think a lot of that comes from the Cold War. So it is quite close to the Cold War in time, this. It's only 10 years since the... 12 years, anyway, since the end of the Cold War. And those people that you mentioned, Donald Rumsfeld, Dick Cheney, they'd been Cold War hawks. And so many of the neoconservative intellectuals around them, and even people who haven't previously been neoconservatives, so people like Christopher Hitchens, they're kind of steeped in that idea of cold war good versus evil you know we are on the side of of progress modernity reason they're on the side of barbarism and i think that plays a huge part that this is almost the last generation i think who you know it's the sort of last, they're a sort of pre-postmodernist generation.
那种道德使命感，我认为很大程度上源自冷战。所以从时间上看，这与冷战相当接近。距离冷战结束仅仅过去了10年——12年吧。而你提到的那些人，唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德、迪克·切尼，他们都是冷战时期的鹰派。他们周围的许多新保守主义知识分子，甚至那些以前并非新保守主义者的人，比如克里斯托弗·希钦斯，都深深浸淫在冷战时期善恶对立的理念中。你知道，我们代表着进步、现代性、理性的一方，而他们代表着野蛮的一方。我认为这起到了巨大的作用，这几乎是最后一代人，我认为他们——这是一种前现代主义的一代人。
They absolutely believe in good versus evil, right versus wrong. And, you know, it's not about competing narratives. It's about genuine, absolute moral truths. Absolutely. But it leads, it ends up with figures in Baghdad jails, you know, being electroded and being carried around, you know, being leashed like dogs. And it leads to the West trampling on the law, you know, the frameworks of international law,
他们绝对相信善恶之分、正义与邪恶。而且，这无关互相竞争的叙事，而是关乎真正绝对的道德真理。完全正确。但它导致的结果是，巴格达监狱里的人们——你知道，遭受电击，被当成狗一样拴着脖子游街。它导致西方践踏了法律，你知道，国际法的框架，
the understanding of human rights that supposedly they're going to war to defend. And the mirror image of that is what bin Laden is doing to the reputation of Islam. Because for lots of people who are now who are not Muslim, thanks to bin Laden and thanks to the cycle of terrorism that he helped to inspire, Islam is now synonymous with jihad, which is synonymous with bombs on tube trains. Yes. And so I think that, and that's why we began, I said, I think it's actually about globalization. I think it's about these two great globalizing forces, Islam and Christendom, the West, whatever you want to call it. They've both been fighting a proxy war over the past 20 years.
以及他们宣称要通过战争来捍卫的人权理念。而这面镜子的另一半，就是本·拉登对伊斯兰教声誉所做的事情。因为对于许多现在还不是穆斯林的人来说，由于本·拉登以及他所帮助激发的恐怖主义循环，伊斯兰教现在成了“圣战”的同义词，而这又成了地铁列车上炸弹的同义词。是的。所以我认为，这就是为什么我们一开始说，我认为这实际上关乎全球化。我认为这关乎伊斯兰教和基督教世界（即西方，无论你想怎么称呼它）这两大伟大的全球化力量。在过去的20里，它们一直在进行代理人战争。
They've both completely trashed their brands. And, of course, you know, we emerge, you know, the Americans are leaving Afghanistan. It's not even as though, you know, the Taliban or indeed ISIS, you know, they're now left to fight each other. So they're, I mean, it's kind of squalid fight over the spoils there. So it's not like they've won any great victory either. And lurking on the eastern borders is China, which it does not have a kind of universalizing mission or vision. It's pure nationalist vision. Yeah, and all the smoke was kind of civilizational, perhaps you might say,
它们的品牌形象都已经彻底破产。当然，你知道，我们浮现出来——你知道，美国人正在撤出阿富汗。甚至都不是说塔利班或ISIS——你知道，他们现在只能互相厮杀。所以他们，我的意思是，这是一场为战利品而展开的肮脏厮杀。所以这并不意味着他们赢得了什么伟大的胜利。而潜伏在东部边境的是中国，它并没有那种普世化的使命或愿景。它只有纯粹的民族主义愿景。是的，所有那些带有文明论色彩的烟雾，也许你可以这么说，
but all the smoke that's lifted from 9-11 is fading away. And what we see is a world where America in pursuit of a kind of universalizing mission has trashed its brand, massively overloaded its credit card. And China has gone through, you know, leaps and bounds. So actually, you know, Bin Laden wanted to bleed America to death. that was his ambition he wanted to provoke america to to do exactly what it did um but but but it's not islam that's benefited from it it's china but tom does that do you think then that um in the grand scheme in the grand sweep of history in the in the very grand scheme of things do you think 9-11 really matters i mean china was going to rise anyway american power was arguably at its peak in the 1990s and bound to
但所有从9·11事件中升起后又消散的烟雾正在渐渐远去。我们看到的是这样一个世界：美国为了追求某种普世化的使命而毁了自己的品牌，极大程度地透支了自己的信用。而中国却通过——你知道，大踏步地前进了。所以实际上，你知道，本·拉登想把美国拖得流血过多而死，那是他的野心，他想挑起美国做出它最终所做的那些举动……但是，但是，但是，从中受益的并不是伊斯兰教，而是中国。不过汤姆，你觉得呢，在宏大的历史进程中，在历史的宏大图景里，你认为9·11事件真的重要吗？我的意思是，中国无论如何都会崛起，美国的力量在20世纪90年代可以说是达到了顶峰，本来就会
then decline um islam the tension between islam and the west was already there do you think that it it is it a turning point does it change history in a really grand sort of big picture way do you think i i think that um so jason burke um observer yeah very good fabulous taliban the 9-11 wars uh i think that's as good of a phrase for them as as any i mean i think if you, yeah, 9-11 really mattered. I mean, it rubbed up close against me personally on a couple of occasions. So when my younger daughter was, she must have been only about six months or something, maybe a bit older. Maybe she was three. I can't remember.
随之衰落……伊斯兰教与西方之间的紧张关系本就存在。你觉得它是一个转折点吗？它真的在宏大叙事的层面上改变了历史吗？我是说……我认为……杰森·伯克（Jason Burke），《观察家报》的记者，对，非常棒，写过《塔利班》、《9·11战争》——我认为这是对这场战争最好的称呼之一。我的意思是，如果你问我，是的，9·11真的很重要。我的意思是，它曾好几次与我擦身而过，切切实实地影响到了我。当时我的小女儿——她肯定只有六个月大左右，也许大一点。也许她三岁了。我记不清了。
She was in a pram. She was in a pram and got stuck on a tube at Stockwell, gave up, went up the escalators. As I was going through the escalators, the police were jumping over the escalators, herring down the tracks. And, of course, that was where a suspected suicide bomber was shot. But he turned out not to have been a suicide bomber.
她当时坐在婴儿车里。她坐在婴儿车里，结果被困在斯托克韦尔（Stockwell）的地铁站，我们放弃坐地铁，走上了自动扶梯。正当我往自动扶梯上走的时候，警察从扶梯上跳下来，顺着轨道狂奔。当然，就在那里，一个被怀疑是自杀式炸弹袭击者的人被枪杀 了。但后来证明他根本不是什么自杀式炸弹袭击者。
John Charles de Menezes. Yeah. And, you know, to have been there with my daughter in a pram with all this going on. I mean, it was, you know, living in London, you're kind of privileged. You know, you're not living in the heart of these awful wars. But that was a kind of unsettling experience.
若昂·查尔斯·德梅内塞斯（John Charles de Menezes）。是的。你知道，带着坐在婴儿车里的女儿经历这一切，周围发生着这种事。我的意思是，你知道，住在伦敦，你其实挺优越的。你知道，你并没有生活在这些可怕战争的核心区。但那依然是一次让人感到不安的经历。
And then I went to Iraq. I went to Sinjar city that had been where Yazidis, religious minority, had kind of been protected under Saddam Hussein, lived. And they'd been brutally targeted by the Islamic State, who were the kind of inheritor apparatus of both the Ba'atists and of al-Zarqawi, who'd absolutely kind of brutally treated them, crucified lots of men, slaughtered them, enslaved women and girls. I mean, kind of horrible. And to stand there with the Islamic State kind of a couple of miles away across this flat land was a really frightening experience.
后来我去了伊拉克。我去了辛贾尔（Sinjar）这座城市，雅兹迪人——一个宗教少数群体——曾在萨达姆·侯赛因统治下受到保护并生活在那里。但他们遭到了伊斯兰国（Islamic State）的残酷迫害。伊斯兰国是复兴党人和本·扎卡维势力的继承者，他们极其残酷地对待雅兹迪人，把许多男人钉在十字架上处死，屠杀他们，将妇女和女孩沦为奴隶。我的意思是，非常可怕。站在那里，看着伊斯兰国就在这片平坦大地的几英里外，那真是一次令人恐慌的经历。
I felt my nose was brought up close to the kind of horror that Bin Laden had unleashed, but also the American response to it had unleashed. But having said that, of course, I mean, what's the alternative? The alternative in which Saddam Hussein is still in power? Well, this is the thing about history, isn't it? There are no, there's no magic wand and there's no, you know,
我感觉自己的鼻子紧紧贴在了本·拉登所释放出的那种恐怖之上，同时也贴在了美国对此的回应所释放出的恐怖之上。话虽如此，当然，我的意思是，除此之外还有什么选择呢？难道让萨达姆·侯赛因继续掌权就是唯一的选择吗？这就是历史的奇妙之处，不是吗？世上没有魔杖，也没有……
there's no utopian. But I'm not, I haven't answered your question. I mean, all of this of course is local. I think, I think that the, I think that it's done long-term damage to the, to the moral reputation and the economic stability of the West. And yet when you watch 20 years, and I think that it's done terrible damage
没有乌托邦。但我还没回答你的问题呢。我的意思是，所有这一切当然都是局部的。我认为，我认为，它对西方的道德声誉和经济稳定造成了长期的损害。然而，当你回顾这20年，我认为它确实造成了可怕的损害
to the name and the reputation of Islam. Well, I think that's definitely true. And the extraordinary thing is when you watch that documentary, so it's minute by minute, and you see it, you watch the crisis unfolding through the US administration's eyes, that sense of that looming terrible damage seems a world away, doesn't it? Because they're, you know, they're reacting in such human terms to this appalling tragedy.
对伊斯兰教的名声和声誉造成了摧毁性的打击。好吧，我认为这绝对是真的。而最不可思议的是，当你观看那部纪录片时——它是按分钟记录的——你看着危机通过美国政府的官员们的眼睛一步步展开，那种迫在眉睫的巨大破坏感，现在看来仿佛远在天边，不是吗？因为他们，你知道，他们对这场可怕悲剧做出了如此人性化的反应。
And they think far more people died than actually did die. I mean, the general sense, wasn't it, on September 11th was that tens of thousands of people would probably be killed. And even now, that footage, Tom, of the buildings coming down and the smoke rolling through the streets of New York City and the sound of those recordings of the sort of air traffic controllers and so on, I mean, it's heartbreaking, isn't it? It's heartbreaking, but it's also, as the French philosopher Jean baudrillard notoriously i wondered if we would get to him exciting yes people found it exciting i mean it's kind of awful thing to say
而且他们以为死亡的人数远比实际死亡的人数要多得多。我的意思是，9月11日当天普遍的看法是，可能会有几万人丧生。直到现在，汤姆，看着那些大楼倒塌的画面，滚滚浓烟在纽约市的街道上翻滚，耳边回响着空中交通管制员等人的录音，我的意思是，这太让人心碎了，不是吗？这确实让人心碎，但它也正如法国哲学家让·鲍德里亚（Jean Baudrillard）所臭名昭著地指出的那样——我当时还在想我们会不会提到他呢——人们觉得这很刺激。是的，人们觉得这很刺激。我的意思是，这是一种很可怕的说法，
of course i mean it was terrible particularly you know people in New York or Washington, of course, I mean, completely terrible. But also it could not help but evoke images of Independence Day where aliens destroy Washington or Godzilla, where a giant monster roams through the concrete canyons and that kind of dust swirling down. I mean, it looked like a Hollywood film. And Baudrillard's point was that, in a way, that was Bin Laden's great triumph,
当然，我的意思是，这太可怕了，尤其是对纽约或华盛顿的人们来说，当然，绝对是极其可怕的。但同时，它也不可避免地让人联想到《独立日》里外星人摧毁华盛顿的场景，或是《哥斯拉》里巨大怪兽在混凝土峡谷中游荡、尘土飞扬而下的画面。我的意思是，这看起来就像一部好莱坞电影。而鲍德里亚的观点是，从某种程度上说，那是本·拉登最伟大的胜利，
was that he had attacked America in the kind of dimension of the imagination. Yeah, I mean, Baudrillard said basically he gave... It's a bit like that thing about people who watch Formula One races. There's part of them always that's hoping for a massive pileup. And Baudrillard says, you know,
那就是他在想象力的维度上袭击了美国。是的，我的意思是，鲍德里亚基本上说过，他给……这有点像那些观看一级方程式赛车比赛的人。他们内心深处总有一部分人在期待着一场惨烈的大连环车祸。鲍德里亚说，你知道，
haven't we dreamt of this event? Hasn't the entire world, without exception, dreamt of it? No one could not dream of the destruction of a power that had become hegemonic to such a point. In essence, it was the terrorists who committed the deed,
难道我们没有梦想过这样的事件吗？难道全世界无一例外，没有人在梦里想过它吗？没有人不会去梦想去摧毁这样一个权势熏天、达到了这种地步的霸权。从本质上讲，是恐怖分子付诸了行动，
but it is we who wished for it. I mean, I don't think... A lot of people were horrified by that at the In essence, it was the terrorists who committed the deed, but it is we who wished for it. I mean, I don't think, a lot of people were horrified by that at the time, and it was an incredibly controversial essay. But I suppose you could argue Hollywood had created the image of New York being destroyed many times before, you know, bin Laden tried to carry it off. Although, I guess, again, a kind of counterpoint to that would be that perhaps it actually doesn't Although, I guess, again, a kind of counterpoint to that would be that perhaps
但却是我们所有人内心深处渴望着它发生。我的意思是，我并不认为……当时有很多人对此感到惊骇，那是一篇极具争议的文章。但我想你可以辩称，好莱坞早在本·拉登付诸行动之前，就已经无数次创造出纽约被毁灭的影像了。不过，我想，换一个角度来看，或许这其实并不意味着——
it actually doesn't show, you know, bin Laden didn't triumph over American control of the imagination. He showed that he was yet another kind of person, you know, enslaved by it because, you know, as you said,
这并不表明本·拉登战胜了美国对想象力的控制。恰恰相反，这表明他不过是又一个被这种想象力奴役的人，因为，正如你所说的那样，
they were absolutely conditioned by Hollywood films themselves. So perhaps in a way, bin Laden's, you Laden's great spectacle of terror was the greatest tribute that's ever been paid to America's control of the global imagination.
他们自己也完全被好莱坞电影所塑造和规训了。所以或许从某种意义上说，本·拉登那场盛大的恐怖奇观，是对美国对全球想象力的控制所致以的史上最高敬意。
That's a very good note on which to end. And you know what, Tom, we've done this without once mentioning Rudolph Giuliani, which I think is a great achievement on our part, given that of all the stories that came out of 9-11,
这是一个非常完美的结束语。你知道吗，汤姆，我们居然一次都没有提到鲁迪·朱利安尼（Rudolph Giuliani），我觉得这简直是我们的一大壮举。考虑到在9·11事件衍生出的所有故事中，
the rise before Giuliani's reputation is by far the most bizarre and surely worthy of a podcast series in itself. Who would have thought then that, you know, with his baseball cap channeling Churchill, he'd end up outside that garden centre with a die running down his face defending Donald Trump. Okay, so I have mentioned him now. You have mentioned him.
朱利安尼声誉的暴起暴落无疑是最离奇的，绝对值得拍成一个单独的播客系列。谁能想到当时那个戴着棒球帽、模仿丘吉尔风范的人，最后会站在一个园艺中心外面、脸上挂着融化的染发剂去为唐纳德·特朗普辩护呢？好吧，我这不还是把他提到了吗。你确实提到他了。
Thank you very much for listening. And we will be back next time with more historical meanderings. Goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
非常感谢大家的收听。我们下期节目将继续进行更多历史漫谈。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。